Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss.
Aha.
Ja, Fabian, neues Smash.
Sie haben ja schon ein bisschen angeteased, das Ganze.
Hat's den Titel doch aktualisiert, ja?
Ach, hat er aktualisiert.
Ja dann.
GG Eats.
Okay, ich hab festgestellt, wir brauchen umsetzen.
Okay, ich hab festgestellt, wir brauchen unbedingt noch ein paar Bildchen.
Und zwar, was wir überhaupt nicht haben, ist, wir brauchen einmal ein Bild für Mindblown,
GIF.
Den Typ brauchen wir unbedingt, wenn wieder irgendwas so super amazing ist, dass man das
kaum aushalten kann.
Images FS, das will ich binden auf F4, GIF.
So, und jetzt, ich mal gucken, ob das Ganze funktioniert, wenn ich das neu starte.
So, wieviel Zeit haben wir noch?
17 Minuten, ja wunderbar, das passt.
Oh!
Ich hab's kaputt gemacht.
Ich hab's zerstört.
But why?
Ah, weil es F4 doppelt gibt.
Ich bin ja auch Anu, muss ich auf F5 binden.
Schreckt.
Ah, funktioniert, perfekt.
So, dann starten wir das andere mal neu und gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Ich hab das jetzt ja netzwerkfähig gemacht.
Bam, funktioniert, jawoll.
Sehr schön.
Hey, stop working, Battlefield 4.
Ja, in Battlefield 4 tut es gerne, aber macht ihr nichts draus.
Mit Battlefield 5 werden die Zeiten wieder kommen, dass es am Anfang crasht.
So, was brauchen wir noch für ein Emote?
Wir brauchen eigentlich noch einen großen Poggers.
Problem ist, Leute, kennt ihr, ich brauch das Poggers Emote transparent.
Transparent und in ordentlicher Größe.
Hat da jemand zufällig was?
Ich finde nämlich nichts.
Ist alles Mist, was ich finde.
Poggers, Alter, Poggers.
Ach so, gleich da kann tatsächlich weg, das ist richtig.
Sebarer, das stimmt.
Also Poggers brauch ich noch in groß.
Und wenn man wieder Amerika gelobt wird, brauchen wir den hier noch.
Der ist ganz wichtig.
Kokona.
Sechs Binden.
So, und dann brauchen wir noch, was haben wir noch?
Eine Blast RNG brauchen wir auch noch.
Dann haben wir, für alle Situationen sind wir gewappnet.
Ich habe jetzt, ohne Scheiß, ich habe jetzt, glaube ich, 30 sogar, 30 Emotes.
Wir sind jetzt wirklich gewappnet für alle, für alle Sachen.
Ok, font ist alles.
Eigentlich bräuchte man noch ein Gachi-Bass oder sowas.
Was?
Songking?
Nein, Songking habe ich nicht.
Das ist das große Sinking-Emoji.
Das ist drum.
Das ist bestimmt nicht so ein komisches Forsen-Emoot oder sowas.
Was hat Nintendo eigentlich für Musik laufen?
Hör mal mal.
Nichts.
Auch gut.
Es läuft ja auch nichts bei Nintendo.
Lol, Alter.
Moin.
Tan-Drexo.
Ich kann den Namen leider nicht richtig lesen, weil mein Bella-Twitch-TV ist der Meinung,
dass sein Name schwarz ist und ich habe das dunkle Twitch-Theme aktiviert.
Exposed-Band.
Ok.
Ich glaube jetzt haben wir wirklich für jedes nur erdenkliche Sache, die in irgendeinem
Stream passieren kann oder in irgendwas aus der Restream.
Jetzt haben wir wirklich für alles irgendeinen Emote am Start.
Am wichtigsten war natürlich, dass er hier noch dabei ist.
Eigentlich bräuchte man eigentlich so ein Wrecked-Emoot oder sowas.
Was gibt es denn da Schönes?
Was hat man hier?
Wrecked-Gif.
Die sind alle dumm.
Den haben sie ja auch für so ziemlich alles mittlerweile schon.
Ist ja blöd.
Das Platoon-Royale.
Die Royale wird sich reißen nicht ab.
Nintendo-Online-Royale gibt es dann.
Last Man Standing Online-Modus.
Mehr schafft der Server nicht.
Das ist wahrscheinlich wirklich so.
Der Nintendo-Online-Modus wird wahrscheinlich wirklich Battle-Royale.
80 Millionen Leute, was weiß ich, wie viele wollen drauf.
So viele können es nicht sein, so viele Switches gibt es da gar nicht.
Es wollen ein paar Millionen Leute drauf.
Ich kenne es nicht.
Battle-Royale.
Keine Plus-5 drauf.
So, dann machen wir das Ding mal im VLC auf.
Die haben wir aber dicht.
Katze.
Ich habe einen Stern auf Github.
Und einen Pull-Request.
Den Pull-Request habe ich schon gesehen.
Falls Dreckiger Dan am Start ist.
Ich habe mir das auch angeguckt.
Ich finde es von der Idee her gut.
Ich bin aber überhaupt kein Fan von XML.
Wenn Konfig, dann etwas anderes.
Ich habe auch selbst ein bisschen herumgebastelt.
Ich kann es doch nicht merken.
Ich muss mir erst mal überlegen, wie ich das genau machen will.
So.
Auf geht es, Nintendo.
Jason-Konfig.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich.
Wobei eigentlich gar keine Konfig.
Wir brauchen es nicht.
Ich habe es jetzt so gemacht.
Ihr habt es vielleicht schon gerade gesehen.
Ich mache einfach einen Keybinding-Unterstrich an den Namen von dem File.
Wenn ich jetzt mal ein Minboard starte,
bindet er mir auf Steuerung C das Image.
Auf Steuerung B das Image.
Auf Steuerung 1 das Image.
Ich finde, da braucht man gar keine Konfig.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen dreckreich.
Ein bisschen durch die Brust ins Auge.
Aber ich finde, dafür, dass mich Konfig dateilt.
Noch Interesse an den Poggers.
Hab eins gefunden.
Ja, schick her.
Schick her.
Mit Keylogger, oder?
Also ich hoffe mal mit Keylogger.
Sonst wäre ich enttäuscht jetzt.
Dann schauen wir mal, was Nintendo zu bieten an neun Minuten.
Um nochmal zurückzukommen auf den Online-Modus von Nintendo.
Hat wirklich einen Poggers gefunden.
Das einzige Problem bei dem Poggers ist,
dass ein Copyright-Logo schräg drüber ist.
Das ist ein bisschen sehr offensichtlich,
dass ich den dann irgendwo geklaut hab.
Kannst vermarkten bei MemeTool.
Ja, easy money.
Ich meine, das ist echt geil, ne?
Wenn man sich mal so überlegt,
eigentlich braucht sowas jeder Streamer.
Ich hab jetzt auf dem zweiten Monitor und die meisten, ne?
Die meisten haben ja heute, also die das ein bisschen,
nennen wir es mal professioneller machen,
die haben ja alle, alle haben sie einen zweiten Rechner,
über den sie streamen,
beziehungsweise einen zweiten Monitor zumindest oder sowas, ja?
Und die Kombination aus Keybindings plus auf dem zweiten Monitor,
quasi eine Übersicht mit Bildchen,
wenn du halt draufklickst,
dann kommt das auf dem Hauptbildschirm, wo gestreamt wird.
Das ist eigentlich was, das braucht jeder Streamer.
Es müssen ja keine dummen Meme-Bildchen sein wie bei mir.
Ich meine, das kann ja im Endeffekt alles sein, was da drauf einblendest.
Und sei es nur der stündliche Sellout.
Ich meine, das ist wirklich praktisch an sich das Tool für Streamer.
Dann finden wir noch einen Mario Facepalm.
Alter, was wird hier rumgeheult im Hintergrund?
Okay, Mario, das kann man echt machen.
Mario Facepalm transparent.
Was, was ist denn da schön von?
Nope, das machen wir nicht.
Das ist gleich Instant Band von Nintendo am Start.
Was ist da?
Ich meine, das ist einfach nicht übel.
Moin, einsetzt D.
Einsetzt D.
Mario Facepalm.
Ein was? Ein was bitte?
Ein GIF C-2000.
Da ist ein Kilo gerade drin.
Ich wusste es, exposed.
So, ich brauche einen ordentlichen Mario Facepalm.
Hier den Hammer Bros. Facepalm nehmen.
Jetzt wird der ein schlimmer als das andere.
Ich meine, der ist im Prinzip auch nicht schlecht dafür.
Den machen wir auch nochmal rein.
F, wo war man jetzt? F7 oder so, bei Quick Bindings.
F8.
Sad Mario.
Und das Schöne ist, mein Dashboard auf dem zweiten Bildschirm
zieht sich sogar die Bilder aus meinem Hauptprogramm
ohne dass ich sie dort hinkopieren muss, über das Netzwerk.
Habt ihr Ubisoft schon nachgeholt?
Nein, wir haben weder Sony noch Ubisoft uns angeguckt.
Ich mein, vielleicht machen wir das danach auch noch.
Irgendwie sind die Mario Facepalms alle ganz schön, ganz schön doof.
Hat er immer ein schönes Mario Facepalm?
Das da.
Das wäre nicht schlecht.
Das sind das, das sind das.
Ich guck nochmal transparent, muss doch auch ein transparent geben.
Ich speichere den Krempel jetzt einfach als was auch immer
Nehmt noch das Bild mit Mario und Luigi, ne ne
Also wenn ihr wollt, und mal gucken wie lange Nintendo geht, aber die sind ja meistens relativ, relativ zackig
Können wir uns danach noch ein bisschen die Highlights angucken von Sony und von Ubisoft
Ich hab gehört das Foto auf der Bühne war bei Ubisoft
Und irgendein verwirrendes Game vorgestellt hat
Komm ich nehm jetzt das hier
Ok, neu laden
Zack, das funktioniert echt gut muss ich sagen
Da hab ich ja was anderes programmiert
Ja, Fonst
Nein das sieht scheiße aus, aber ich mein besser als nix
Programming Skills
Bist du dieses Jahr auf der Gamescom wahrscheinlich nicht
Gamescom ist total sinnlos
Ich hab mir jetzt ja mal zwei Jahre die volle Ladung gegeben
Also mit fast einer Woche da, plus den ganzen Tag irgendwelche Termine, plus den ganzen Tag sinnlos Gelaber
Da kommt so wenig bei rum
Und letztendlich fährst du fast besser
Du guckst jetzt von daheim aus an in Ruhe
Ist leider so
Gamescom kann man machen, wenn man das noch nie gemacht hat, aber an sich, ich weiß nicht
Eigentlich, da kommt auch so wenig bei rum letztendlich
So, machen wir mal aus
Ah komm, dauert noch zwei Minuten
Schauen wir mal, ich wollte eigentlich was essen
Welp mir grad so ein
Lul
Mega lul
Ok, ich nehm jetzt das hier
Ja, ein Tag, aber für einen Tag lohnt sich's wiederum nicht
Sich alles Mögliche zu besorgen
Weißt du, wenn ich den schon einen Ausweis aus den Rippen leiern muss für zwei Personen
Da stellen sie sich nämlich immer extrem an
Oh wir haben einen Poggers, nice
Poggers, ok
Poggers, den hauen wir jetzt noch ganz schnell rein
Poggers
Ach komm, den hauen wir jetzt nächstes Mal rein, wir haben jetzt schon den Mario dabei
Poggers, Poggers, alter Poggers
Ach komm, wir können noch neu starten
Schnell
Famous last words
Geht schnell
Hast du jetzt das Copyright raus, Photoshopped oder was?
Könntest du mir richtig vorstellen
So, Max beschwert sich ja auf dem Bild, es ist ein Copyright Schriftzug drauf
Was macht er?
Ja, komm einfach Copyright Schriftzug raus, Photoshopped
Poggers, Poggers Photoshop Skills
Oh, wow
Jetzt gehts los
Dieser Switch Sound immer
Zu leise, zu leise Nintendo
Ok
Wenn 100% nicht genug ist
Immer noch zu leise, oder?
Nintendo, was macht ihr denn?
Jetzt, so ist gut, oder?
Ist das Nintendo, was wir hier gucken?
Was, was, was sehe ich da gerade?
Ist das Nintendo?
Ja, ja das ist wirklich Nintendo
Was, was, was sehe ich da gerade?
Ist das Nintendo?
Ja, ja das ist wirklich Nintendo
Was?
Was zum Teufel war das?
Alle Weeps am Start
Oh, jetzt reihen sie aber
Oh, muss ich leise machen?
Die Dinger sind unterschiedlich laut abgemischt irgendwie
Das ist tatsächlich laut
Ja, das ist ein JRPG-Schicht
Ist das Tales of schlechte Grafik
Ah ne, Xenoblade
Nani?
Ich hab das nicht gespielt
Keine Ahnung, da müsst ihr den Master-Grabber mal fragen
Also
Das ist, Fabian, das war's für dich, oder?
Das macht, das macht Money bei Nintendo
Oh nein, es wird cringe
RL-Videos werden immer
Genau, so läuft es in echt auch immer, wenn du irgendwo rumstehst
Mario-Party-Royal
Also, wenn die, wenn das offline ist, weil Fabian schreibt es ja auch gerade, also wenn das wirklich wieder nur offline ist oder halt irgendwas, was nicht da auch gescheit ist, dann ist es wirklich nur offline
Ich meine, ja okay, es ist ja gut, dass man es fördern will, dass die Leute offline spielen können und wenn sie sich offline befreuen, sich offline treffen und spielen, sagt ja keiner was gegen
Aber heutzutage wollen auch die Leute online spielen
Auch wenn das Nintendo nicht wahrhaben will
Fire Emblem oder irgendwie sowas
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung
Oder auch nicht
Oder doch
Oder nicht
Fire Emblem, sag ich doch
Edelgard, so heißen Leute auch nur in japanischen RPGs, Edelgard
Die Japaner sind geil, wenn sie so fake deutsche Namen immer nehmen
Ich wollte auch schon immer mal in der Armee sein, angeführt von Edelgard
Ich will immer noch in der Armee sein
Fortnite
Nein, nicht Fortnite
Das sieht aber sehr edelig
Oder warte ist das, ist das doch Fortnite
Es ist auf jeden Fall, ja es ist Fortnite
Endlich, endlich da hab ich drauf gewartet
Ja genau, das bist du ja noch spielst
Genau Fabian, denkst du mir auch
Overcooked 2
Das seh ich der erste Teil als Overcooked 2
Kennt ihr mal den ersten Teil
Was? Vambo will ein 0-4-D
Leute wollt ihr auch 0-4-D? 0-4-D kann ich erst machen, wenn mindestens 10 Leute 0-4-D sehen wollen
Okay, 0-4-D, hier 0-4-D, nur für euch
Super Spinning 0-4-D HD Edition
Das ist aber gut, das Game ist gut
Terrific
Nee
Das gucken wir uns nicht mehr an
Stimmt, es sind ja die Splatoon World Championships
Splatoon eSports
Splatoon eSports, lol
Das sieht nice aus, das Game, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie sie spielen wird, aber mir gefällt unglaublich, wie das ausschaut
Ich kann das auch
Moment, ist Arena of Valia, Moment, äh, nicht das Sturzstein abbringen, war das nicht das Crytek Moba?
Das hieß doch so, das war Arena of Fate
Oh, Just Dance 2019, endlich
Oh, FIFA, komm on, Bra
Ack, komm on, Bra, muss das sein
Ja, das war ganz okay, Paladins wird ja immer schlimmer
Nee, Dark Souls wie Master, warum nicht
Monster Hunter, okay, das ist bestimmt für einige geil
Wolfenstein 2 doch jetzt nach einem Jahr kommt, das haben wir auf der Switch raus
Mario Tennis
Und immer wenn ich das sehe, kann ich nicht helfen, aber lachen
Oh, jetzt geht der Fabian ab
Hi, ich bin Masahiro Sakurai von Sora Ltd. Heute möchte ich euch das neue Super Smash Bros. Game für die Nintendo Switch vorstellen
Wie ihr wisst, Super Smash Bros. ist ein Action-Game, das über die liebsten Spielcharaktere auf dem Bild geht
Viele Kämpfer sind in dieser Serie gekommen. Ich bin mir sicher, dass ihr alle ewig seid, um herauszufinden, wer dieses Mal auf dem Roster teilnehmen wird
Also haben wir ein Video gemacht, um einige Kämpfer in der Serie zu zeigen
Der Nummer neben jedem Kämpfer signifiziert die Ordnung, in der sie in die Super Smash Bros. Serie teilnehmen
Bitte schaut euch das Video an
Jetzt ist es wieder leiser, die Musik, Nintendo kann sich auch nicht entscheiden, oder?
Was ist das für eine Zelda? Das war weder die Twilight-Princess-Zelda, das war weder die Breath of the Wild-Zelda
Sieht anders aus
Alles klein war es, denn angeblich voll OP habe ich gelesen. Stimmt das, Fabian? Kennt sich das auch aus?
Was macht da Cloud drinne? Der hat doch genauso wie Snake. Was haben die da eigentlich drinne zu suchen?
Vielleicht funktioniert das zuerst.
dye
des
Gibt es jetzt dreimal link oder ist es ein
skin ich kenne mich für smash überhaupt nicht auf
drei verschiedene links ok warum
yes
that's right every fighter in super smash brothers history is joining the battle indeed
absolutely every super smash brothers fighter ever is in this game whether they were originally
Klingt mir nach einem Balancing-Albtraum, so viele Helden zu haben.
Also so als Außenstehender, ich hab wie gesagt von der Serie keine Ahnung.
Klingt aber nach nicht zu balancen mit irgendwie, was weil eh wie vielen Helden drinnen.
So viele Helden, so viele Helden.
Mario ist noch einfach zu benutzen, aber wir haben noch etwas für jemanden aus seiner aktuellen Erleichterung.
Er kann auch seine Wettbewerbe und Bauernoutfits tragen.
Link baut seinen Wettbewerb von der Legend der Zelda, Breath of the Wild.
Seine Bombe werden nun weitermacht.
Und sein letzten Schuss entleuchtet seine Waffe.
Er kann auch Link's bekannte Tunik von der Wilde tragen.
Obwohl es lange war, kamen die 2-in-1-Fighter, die Ice Climbers, zurück.
Schaut euch mal zusammen mit Nanna, wenn sie weg ist, dann habt ihr wirklich Probleme.
Bestimmt noch, bestimmt ein NES oder sowas oder noch davor.
Mit seinem Aussehen aus Fire Emblem Radiant Dawn.
Jetzt könnt ihr beide Versionen zum ersten Mal benutzen.
Die 2 verschiedene Versionen werden sogar ein wenig anders ausgesprochen.
Wir haben nun die weibliche Version von Pikachu, komplett mit einem scharfen Haar.
Habt ihr gemerkt, dass Pikachu-Libre eine Frau ist?
Krill Pikachu, da kann er nächstes Mal schief gehen jetzt.
In 1-in-1-Fighten wird Mew immer wieder seine Gegner treffen, wie in seinen ersten Spielen.
Es ist ein kleiner Tuch, der die Tatsache des Schusses reduziert.
Schussmögliche Bewegungen, wie Samus' Schussmögliche, können nun im Mittelpunkt aufsteigen.
Ich fühle mich gerade im Prinzip so, ich habe so keinen Plan davon.
Es sind zehn Jahre seit seiner letzten Appearance in der Serie,
damit wir endlich ein paar neue Schussmögliche machen können.
Natürlich ist Shadow Moses Island auch wieder da.
King Dedede's Final Smash ist eigentlich ein Käge-Fight, in dem er Missile und ein Jet-Hammer eröffnet.
Pikachu kommt auch von Super Smash Bros. Melee.
Seine elektrischen Schüsse verletzen sich auch, also sei vorsichtig.
In The Legend of Zelda, das ist die Welt.
Zelda ist mehr in der Forschung als im Kampf,
denn ihr Design ist in The Legend of Zelda, das ist die Welt.
Zelda ist viel mehr elegant und regal als unsere anderen Schüsse,
aber wir haben sicherlich keine energetischen Schüsse.
Der Final Smash ist ein Schussmögliche, genannt Triforce of Wisdom.
Sonic's Final Smash, Super Sonic, ist mehr in der Forschung als jemals.
Einerseits bist du zu langsam, oder er ist zu schnell.
Pac-Man hat auch eine Schussmögliche dieses Mal.
Sie zu lösen auf der Bühne klingt wie Pac-Man, nicht wahr?
Was denkst du?
Pac-Man Trainer ist zurück mit Squirtle, Ivysaur und Charizard.
Du kannst Pokémon während des Kampfes verändern,
und dieses Mal gibt es keine Bedeutung für einen, also fühl dich frei, deinen Main zu wählen.
Du kannst auch als Mädchen Trainer spielen, für das erste Mal.
Einige Kämpfer, wie Captain Falcon, haben einen dramatischen Slow-Mo-Effekt,
bei starken Attacken in einem-zu-einigen Kampfen.
Und natürlich ist sein hazardous Big Blue Stage zurückgekommen.
Wie vorher, kannst du in deinem Final Fantasy VII Kostüm
oder in deinem Final Fantasy VII Advent Children Kostüm spielen.
Jetzt kannst du den Limit-Gauge in deinem Damage-Vertrag sehen.
Speziale Displays sind auch für bestimmte anderen Kämpfer disponibel.
Zum Beispiel.
Du kannst sehen, wie lange Robin mit Levensword und Tomes benutzen kann.
Wer zum Teufel ist Robin?
Für Villager ist es einfacher, zu sehen, was du verpackt hast.
Zwischen den männlichen und den jungen Versionen gibt es acht verschiedene Villager.
Bowsher's Final Smash, Gigabowser, ist noch größer und besser.
Er ist nun so groß wie Bowsher aus dem Yoshi's Island-Game.
Die ganzen Bewegungen von Mr. Game & Watch sind zurück und er sieht sogar mehr aus als er in seinen ersten Spielen sah.
Seine Transformations sind mehr als die aller Zeiten.
Young Link aus Super Smash Bros. Melee macht einen Reaktion, der für den ersten Mal drei Links macht.
Wozu? Ich sage es jetzt mal so als Smash Noob.
Kirby ist sein normaler Puffy-Self.
Aber wir haben etwas zu seinem Stahl-Abilität zusammengestellt.
Er hat eine Kopie-Abilität für jeden Kämpfer.
Also, je mehr Kämpfer wir haben, desto schwieriger wird er werden.
Shulk nutzt wiederum Knopfpumpe, um Monado-Arten zu handeln.
Aber jetzt kannst du einen speziellen mit Knopfpumpe und einem schnellen Direktions-Tippen wählen.
Er ist sicher am Eskalieren.
Ich gebe euch auch Yorra zu seinem Final Smash.
Ganondorf erhebt sich wieder, zurück zu seinem populären Design aus The Legend of Zelda, Ocarina of Time.
Und für seinen Final Smash wird er Demon King Genn.
Die Proportionen von Knopfpumpe haben ein wenig verweigert.
Es gibt drei Typen. Brawler, Swordfighter und Gunner.
Die Bewegung für jeden Typen wurde ebenfalls erhöht.
Und jetzt kannst du von zwölf Voice-Options wählen.
Wir hoffen, dass dieser Kämpfer online gespielt wird.
Der letzte Spiel für Samus' Final Smash war drei geheimnisvolle Schilder.
Diesmal werden wir ihn auf der Leitenden Schilder erheben.
Im letzten Spiel hat Samus' Final Smash ihre Schilder eingeführt.
Jetzt wird Samus' Schilder auf der Leitenden Schilder erheben.
Wenn Olimar beschädigt wird, wird er in seinem Helm ein Schuss sehen.
Aber keine Sorge, er wird sofort aufgebaut.
Bayonetta hat die ersten zwei Spielkostüme von Samus' Final Smash.
Listen closely and you'll hear differences in the sound effects.
It seems we have a guest.
Rodan appears as an assist trophy.
Wario's Final Smash, Wario-Man, has changed quite a bit.
After transforming, he no longer uses individual attacks to get the job done.
Donkey Kong's Final Smash is all rapid-fire punches, like Donkey Kong Jungle People.
You'll notice that he and other fighters have expressive new facial animations.
Little Man's Final Smash is now a bunch of blows from Giga Man.
In fact, all Final Smash moves in the game get right to the punch.
Nessa's new Final Smash calls on Paula and Pooh.
Of course, Jeff still shows up as an assist trophy.
Likewise, Lucas' Final Smash features Kumatora and Boney.
At first glance, Wii Fit Trainer seems the same, but her face has a new look.
I wavered a bit on whether to change it, but it was a request from the Wii Fit developers.
We've included all the hazards from both versions of Mega Man's stage from Super Smash Bros. for Wii U and Nintendo 3DS.
And for his Final Smash, say hello to Proto Man and Base.
Palutena's special attacks have been streamlined this time around.
And her down special is now both a counter and a deflector.
Herzlich willkommen in this video.
In this video, we're going to talk about some of the best Final Smash games in the game.
First of all, the Final Smash.
The Final Smash is a game in which you have to fight a lot of enemies.
And you have to fight a lot of enemies.
Allow me to introduce a brand new Echo Fighter.
Daisy joins the roster as Peach's Echo Fighter.
She fights in a similar manner as Peach, but they have different characteristics, which we hope you'll enjoy.
Have fun playing as your favorite princesses.
All in all, if you add up the changes we're making, there could be tens of thousands.
I hope you're looking forward to some serious matchups.
And here's a new fighter.
If you ink opponents, they'll take more damage from attacks.
Different weapons are available as Smash attacks or special attacks.
The Splattershot, Splatbomb, Splatroller and the Final Smash Killer Whale.
You can actually run out of ink, so it's important to refill by pressing the B button while shielding.
The Inkling Boy also debuts alongside the Ink Girl.
And each has their own ink color, so matches get really bright.
By the way, we added in the Squid Sisters as an assist trophy.
During their live concert, the camera zooms in for a close-up.
That means it's easier to get knocked off the screen.
While we're on the topic of assist trophies, let's share some information on them.
As you may know, assist trophies lend helpful support in battles.
You can KO assist trophies by clicking on damage, and now you get points for each other.
However, some assist trophies will remain unbeatable.
Maybe an unexpected guest will photobomb your battles.
Yep, it's him.
There's a wide variety. More than 50 of them appear in the game.
Of course, we're also adding even more Pokémon and items. We can't wait to show you.
There are a variety of stages available in this game as well, including a massive list of returning stages.
If you get a group together to play, it'll be a fun experience.
The graphics have been improved as well. Let's get a look at some stages from various games.
The music is awesome.
Let's take a sneak peek at the new and returning techniques you can pull off during battles.
The directional air dodge enhances mobility.
It can come in handy when recovering from a fall.
However, if you dodge too much, even on the ground, you'll be wide open to attack and your duration of intangibility gets shorter.
You can execute short hop attacks by pressing the A button and jump at any time.
Also, you can smash attacks by pressing the A and B buttons just like the previous game.
A perfect shield occurs when you release the shield button.
Until now, you were able to pull it off without any major risk, but going forward, you'll need to time it carefully.
For one-on-one battles, the damage dealt will now be greater than in battles.
This should help ensure that the action is well paced.
In a timed battle, the fighter in the lead will sometimes splash with light.
Better do something, or no victory pose for you.
We've got something special for your playing pleasure in Super Smash Bros. Ultimate.
This was information overload. Oh, it's not finished yet. Classic controller. Poggers.
Finally. I hope this works for other games as well.
Finally. I hope for the search for a better controller.
In fact, all fighters' current Amiibo figures will be supported, even if they're from a different series.
Tap a compatible Amiibo figure to add in a figure player, or FP, and level up.
Your FP data from previous titles can be transferred.
We hope you're as excited as we are. Our staff will continue working hard until the game releases. We really appreciate your support.
We've made including every single fighter ever our number one goal, so I'm kind of hoping you aren't expecting too many new challenges.
However, we do have one more announcement. Please take a look.
Not actual game footage.
The hat? The hat?
No, not yet.
I thought the hat from Bionis would come as a fighter.
Link has exploded.
No more cells.